very nice to have you on the program
thanks for coming i am a big fan and i'm
really happy to be here oh thank you
very much for supporting that
i i think you're the best thank you
after that two
thing i lost yeah you know um
yeah i want to ask you about uh first of
all the the thing that it's interesting
because
people my age first saw you in roots and
everyone knows you from that
but uh you've got this whole new
generation of fans with the star trek
gig i like to say and i was curious
first of all
that thing you wear over your eyes the
visor
is that thing a pain in the ass or what
i mean what's the story with that
actually the truth is it is painful and
not necessarily in the ass
but we i'm glad to hear
that no it hooks on to the ass
and then there's a strut that moves its
way up
i had no idea believe it or not
believe it or not we screw this thing
into my head
what that is happening you look at the
show and i'm always like an idiot
looking at the show like how does that
happen how does that stay on how did
they screw it into your skull
screw it into my head now that's what
you need an agent for
we want to give levar burton this new
role but right he has to have something
screwed into the side of his head good
news is you're in star trek the bad news
is
really so how far do they screw it in i
mean just enough to give me a migraine
no more than that no more than that so
like if but if you sneezed it would stay
on
absolutely stay on that's the point okay
but you can see through it right not at
all
you can't see through it eighty percent
of my vision is taken away when i put
that that is so annoying i would think
so you just have to rely like when
you're eating food in the commissary
that you know you need someone to tell
you
it looks okay today lavar well conan and
i i don't wear it off the set
what
you mean you're not really that
character
oh major bummer
but uh what was uh what was it like
getting to coming to grips with the fans
uh
fans uh for star trek shows the original
and the subsequent shows
they're they're just so rabid i mean
it's great they're very loyal
but they're incredibly like devoted to
probably to the point of distraction are
they hard to deal with well
i i prefer to refer to them as as
really enthusiastic so rabid
likening them to a a dog with a frothing
mouth
is probably not a good thing well i
consider that
these are the people that are putting my
children through college bingo
and and so i i tend to be nice to them i
mean sometimes they can be very intense
though
very intense i don't do a lot of them
but you know about these star trek
conventions
yes i do
yes i actually i've never been to one
but i yes i understand they're very
they're quite intense
well there was there was a woman once
that came up to me dressed in klingon
garb
a rather large woman that insisted that
i sign her breast
sign her breasts and her breasts and we
all know that the klingons they have
easily removable
garb on top that's right and so did you
sign the
well i was faced with this massive
they were large yeah so you started
writing a letter
dear ma'am it's nice to meet you
i continued on next breast
i signed it you signed it any
opportunity to
please a fan good for you you're a good
man that way
let me ask you uh you know it's it's
funny because i said in the intro it's
it's been 20 years
since fruits which is which is amazing
because where were you
january 23rd 1977 which was the i was
in high school it was my freshman year
in high school and uh
and i remembered uh it was just this
giant event
i mean people there hadn't been i don't
think there had been a tv show correct
me if i'm wrong it had been on
consecutive nights like a mini series
which was the second mini series rich
man poor man was the first and it aired
in weekly installments but roots was
the first opportunity to to program in
eight consecutive
nights it had never been which at the
time was this was this stunning
idea i mean today might not seem strange
to people but that was very unusual who
thought of that why did they think of
that idea
the the the programming genius at abc
behind that decision was that
their thinking was you know what we like
this we think it's good but it
it's about black people and if nobody
watches
we'll just cut our losses and be done
with it in eight consecutive nights and
the final episode of roots is still the
third most watched
television program in the history of the
medium right yeah
yeah that's great
actually i i believe our christmas
episode is number two for all time
i know it's in the top ten i i wasn't
aware
people must because it was it was one of
those events where
where people do know where they were
at the time you know what they were
doing i mean i remembered watching it
with my brothers
and uh and and i remembered you know
that okay i was a freshman in high
school i remember what i was doing
do people come up to you sometimes and
offer you know where they were
what they were doing yeah i had a guy
come up to me once and actually this was
in prison
um you were in prison for a time well we
were having
the conversation in prison he was
incarcerated i was there
working i was on location and uh you
were filming something you know
something in prison okay filming
something to set the record straight i
appreciate it thank you
good you just gotta make sure you know i
was in prison for a time
uh-huh
and uh avoided the showers and uh
and but you had your visor to god yeah
oh my god uh he this this was a paper
hanger a guy who
made a living uh writing bad checks in
shopping malls and
uh roots aired in january originally uh
in in 77
and this guy told me that he actually
cut his hours short he had a whole crew
of people that were out in the malls
credit card forgery and bad checks and
he would pull them all
out of the malls early so everybody
could get home to watch roots
that's amazing a criminal a career
criminal cut thing short
everybody watched roots yeah now tell us
about
uh you've written a book i don't know
how you find time to do these things but
uh
aftermath a novel of the future actually
i
i wrote this i started this project just
after my daughter was born
two and a half years ago and i wasn't
getting any sleep anyway
so oh that's just that's an interesting
idea i'm up
already i might as well use baby's
trying that's right
most people don't think that way right
we do at my house
so uh so you wrote tell us what the book
is about the book is actually
it's a cautionary tale i call it a
science fiction thriller and
uh i i begin with the premise that um
america is destroyed the last best hope
on earth
has fallen the new madrid fault in the
midwest
uh erupts with a 9.1 magnitude
earthquake and
nasa collapses and creates some economic
factors that contribute to the fall
and uh the race war is really the straw
that brings the camels back
america is engulfed in a civil war and
uh and that's
just the first two interesting ideas
that's the first two
pages then it gets then it really gets
quiet and everyone just has coffee for
the rest of the book
that was wild man those first two pages
tell me about it yeah uh
that that that sounds uh that sounds
fascinating though people should check
this out aftermath it's it's out
everywhere it is
in the bookstores as we speak all right
well thanks so much for coming by it was
really nice talking to you i love you
barbara good morning everybody very nice
to meet you
we're gonna take a break we'll be right
back